نذهب الان الى نجوان سمري مراسله الجزيره
من تل ابيب في ظل
ذوي صافرات على الانذار مجددا في محيط غزه
وهذه الطلقات الصاروخيه
التي اطلقت
[موسيقى]
نجوان كنت قد سالتك عن ما تقوله اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن ست قذائف هاون اطلقت
من القطاع نفذ منها الى الاجواء
الاسرائيليه اربعه بينما تم اسقاط اثنين
عن طريق القبه الحديديه
[موسيقى]
كنت اقول بان بعد تسع ساعات تقريبا منذ
منتصف الليله الماضيه ساده فيها الهدوء
على الجانب
الاسرائيلي لم تطلق خلال هذه الليله اي
قضائف صاروخيه ولم تدوي صافرات الانذار
عادت صباح اليوم ودوت في عده مناطق قبل
قليل دوت في كيسوفيم وبالفعل تم رصد سته
قذائف هاون اطلقت اعترضت منظومه القبه
الحديديه اثنتين منها
والباقي القذائف سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه
الان فقط قبل دقيقه من الان دورت سافرت
الانذار مجددا في منطقه ريم في منطقه غلاف
غزه في الحدود الشرقيه وبالتالي هذا يعني
بان هناك تجدد لسافرات الانذار تجدد
لاطلاق القذائف الصاروخيه انقطاع غزه
باتجاه البلدات
الحدوديه في هذه الاثناء كانت هناك توقعات
اشار اليها
يعني مسؤولون امنيون ونقلتها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه بان اسرائيل تستعد في هذه
الاثناء ربما لرد اخر على اغتيال القيادي
غالي في ساعات الليل الماضيه ولكن حتى
الان هناك متابعه من قبل الجانب
الاسرائيلي لراسك شكل هدف الرد ربما
وبالتالي هناك استعدادات لامكانيه مواصله
هذه هذا التصعيد واطلاق الصواريخ من
الجانب
الفلسطيني من قبل فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه منذ يوم امس تم الاعلان من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان خطه الطوارئ او
التعليمات الاستثنائيه التي اصدرها لسكان
بلدات غلاف غزه المحيطه
بالحدود حتى ما لا يقل عن اربعين كيلو
مترا عن الحدود ستبقى مستمره حتى يوم غد
الجمعه وبالتالي ربما كان في ذلك اشاره ان
هذه العمليه ستستمر هذا وفقا للتعليمات
التي اصدرتها الجبهه الداخليه التابعه
للجيش الاسرائيلي بان كل القيود
والتعليمات المفروضه على السكان في هذه
المناطق تبقى ساريه حتى يوم غد الجمعه
ورغم ما يحدث على الارض عبد السلام ما
زالت هناك جهود وما زالت هناك
محاولات للتواصل الى تفاهم من اجل وقف
لاطلاق النار هناك دول وسطاء عده تعمل من
اجل ذلك يوم امس كان هناك حديث بين مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جاك سوليفان ونظيره
الاسرائيلي الساحره النجبي بحسب ما نقلته
او نقله موقع ولا العبري فقط طلب سوليفان
من نظيره الاسرائيلي احتواء هذا التصعيد
والعمل من اجل وقف اطلاق النار كذلك كانت
هناك محادثه يوم امس بين وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
ونظيره لويد اوستن نظيره الامريكي ورغم ان
البيان الاسرائيلي ربما لم يتطرق لهذه
النقطه وتحدث فقط عن شكر جالنت للوزير
الامريكي على دعم الدائم من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه لاسرائيل وايضا بانه شرح للجانب
الامريكي
الضرورات الامنيه التي اقتضت
واقدمت فيها اسرائيل على اغتيال القاده في
الجهاد الاسلامي هذا وفقا للبيان
الاسرائيلي لكن صباح هذا اليوم نقرا بانه
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعلنت بان هذه
المحادثه خلال المحادثه ايضا طلب الوزير
الامريكي من نظيره الاسرائيلي العمل من
اجل احتواء الموقف وخفض التصعيد والتواصل
الى وقف لاطلاق النار وبالتالي هناك
محاولات
متواصله من جهات عده لوقف اطلاق النار وان
كانت ما يجري على الارض ربما مختلف هناك
ايضا بعض المراقبين في اسرائيل يتحدثون عن
انه يوم امس كان هناك نوع
لقلب الاوراق او خلط الاوراق بعد الرشقه
الصاروخيه التي جاءت في ساعات المساء
ووصلت الى منطقه تل ابيب والمدن المحيطه
بها سواء كان في منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى او
في المدن الواقعه الى الجنوب من تل ابيب
كانت هناك رشاقات كثيفه من الصواريخ في
ساعات المساء في وسط اجواء كانت تتحدث عن
اقتراب التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار
وبالتالي هذا ربما
ادى الى
الرجوع من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي او
التراجع من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي
وهذا ما دفع اسرائيل الى تنفيذ عمليه
الاغتيال هذا مره اخرى وفق رؤيه المحللين
اسرائيليين يتحدثون عما جرى في الساعات
الاخيره الليله الماضيه خلال المشاورات
الامنيه التي اجراها ان نتنياهو بطبيعه
الحال اسرائيل عاده تقدم على عمليات
الاغتيال دون ان تحتاج الى اي فعل من
الطرف الاخر وما يدلل على ذلك بطبيعه
الحال انها هي من بدات بهذا التصعيد وهي
من اقدمت على عمليه الاغتيال دون ان يكون
هناك قذائف قد اطلقت من فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه عبد السلام شكرا